do you believe in the god
[Music]
what if there is no god
you're uh an atheist correct yeah
that's the devil waiting for you in hell
by the way
there's a growing community of people
that identify themselves as
atheists atheism is on the upswing in
america
secular americans now make up nearly a
quarter of the american population where
do they find meaning in life
or how do they shape their morality do
they believe in the spiritual or the
supernatural
how can you really tell if someone is an
atheist
we brought together seven atheists
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is they'll win a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the cash
prize
this is odd men out
[Music]
my game plan is to try and trip people
up by talking about their world view
i have a list of questions prepared my
main goal is just to not get eliminated
immediately
the other half of this is just
convincing everyone that i am an atheist
and i don't think that's going to be
hard to do i'm kind of suspicious of
joey because he has
a profile picture with devil horns but
it also looks like he's jesus
you make fun of religion a little bit in
like a nice way i hope they get it
i'm going to be looking for people who
do not confidently
say why they're an atheist hopefully i
can suss out that christian and bring
home the money
hi hi what's up what's up everyone all
right
i got a question what type of atheist
are you agnostic
secular humanist straight up atheist
agnostic agnostic atheist
agnostic too oh too many agnostics
that's gonna be so hard
anyone grew up with religion no uh i was
raised hindu
race catholic same i was raised catholic
too did joe's race catholic
i know right why'd you leave i was
raised in a colombian catholic family
and being queer as well uh did not
really feel like
the place for me i tapped into a
presbyterian and quakerism but
honestly i'm just better off without
religion i found happiness without
religion pragmatic atheism i would say
would define my atheism more so i'm not
i'm definitely not agnostic
what are you guys's views on
deconverting people loving
i think that's a touchy one i feel like
it's not really my place
i personally have quite a few religious
friends i don't feel like deconverting
them is the right way to go just because
if they
find happiness in their religion that's
good for them you have to
be careful with that yeah because if you
come on too strong then people are you
know
immediately going to shy away do you
think it's moral um i don't know do you
yeah i do i think if if you can offer
that sort of community and world view
that can sort of replace the the whole
that religion leaves you know not just
willy-nilly deconverting people
especially if like maybe they can't
handle the the existential dread that
comes along with it yeah i mean i agree
that like if people want to believe it
then it's okay
but there's also like if someone is open
to hearing about atheism
then i'm all about telling them about it
i had a boyfriend when i was in high
school who
grew up in a christian home but he was
kind of like i really don't know what i
believe and i was like let me tell you
about it that's when we strike
okay so that round was horrifying evan
was so serious
and i was like oh my goodness i don't
know how to respond to you
i'm gonna vote for katie i think i'm
gonna vote for nina this round
just because she didn't really speak
much um emily i think i'm gonna go for
joey
nina emily this round i'm gonna have to
vote for emily
people who have like a sunny disposition
like me
i'm really suspicious of and the person
eliminated this round
is emily
oh my god i think i was being too
friendly i don't know how i feel about
this i think people got that one wrong
but maybe
how do your guys families feel about you
being atheist
they're totally fine with it i don't
think my parents really acknowledge the
fact that i'm an atheist i told my
father one straight up i'm an atheist
and he took away my kindle and my laptop
i actually haven't really told my father
he lives in colombia so i'm glad that
like you know he'll
he probably won't watch this video
whenever my mom is mad at me she'll like
bring up my atheism to like spite me and
i'm like dude
you've known this for like 10 years it's
not going away like
just accept it at first it was really
difficult i had a lot of arguments and
sometimes
my parents would leave the room during
the arguments i learned how to be nicer
about it and be a better communicator
katie i have a question for you um
assuming you have an atheist friend
uh how would you console that atheist
friend
after they had lost a loved one if you
lose somebody it's always going to be
hard
regardless of whether you're christian
or atheist or whatever religion
i don't think that you should say if you
are atheist i don't think you should
fill this void with something else like
i don't want you going to christianity
or
whatever religion to kind of help come
you know comfort you and i think you
should kind of deal with it and just
you know read more philosophy let's do a
quick speed round of just like a
book or an article or something specific
and tangible that you've read
as an atheist i read the end of faith by
sam harris the great agnostic by susan
jacoby which is about
robert ingersoll who's an old orator
from the 1800s applying spaghetti
monster gospel i think is a great work
of atheist literature
the anthropology of rituals is actually
very interesting especially talking
about you know atheist rituals
a lot of like richard dawkins stuff uh
like christopher hinchens uh
witch dawkins honestly i have no clue
which ones but like i'd like no like
but you've read the you've read the
books no like just like his articles and
like his like
his like world view kind of like stuff
what's his career
uh he's like some kind of like
theorist so basically i have no idea
really i actually
studied philosophy in college at nyu any
atheist
thinker that has insulted no atheist
thinkers i mean i've read a lot of
philosophers
and i mean any moves any you know
not not one that i can point off top of
my head now interesting making it
difficult
that round was a little spicy freaking
joey is coming for me joey was
definitely the instigator
i don't know what other people are
thinking but it's kind of suspicious
that he's so over the top if you know
what i mean
yeah i'm gonna vote for nina again just
don't believe her i'm the most
suspicious of
katie honestly katie was acting a little
suspicious and she couldn't name any
atheist works
i'm gonna change my strategy for this
round instead of going for joey's
you know kind of being over the top i'm
going to vote for nina my vote
is gonna go for katie i'm gonna vote for
nina
the votes are in and we have a tie
between
nina and katie that's going to be
interesting
each person will get 20 seconds to state
your case
hey guys i have 20 tattoos on my body my
most recent
one is a tarot card would a christian
have a tarot card tattoo on their body
i don't think so i have a heart on my
finger
i got when i was 16 years old sticking
poked by my ex best friend
i've been watching like the amazing
atheist since i was like 12 years old on
youtube
repsion i've gone to like yeah
um okay so i believe in science i think
religion is a bunch of baloney i think
people just use it to kind of
comfort themselves and give them you
know a sense of hope and
but i think when you're an atheist you
have to look inward and you have to
you know really make your own decisions
and it allows you to be way more
introspective
i think i have my nipples pierced
i still feel like it's
nina i i definitely believe nina so
sorry katie i think i should stick to
katie
i have my nipple pierced katie says she
has her nipples pierced i'm gonna vote
nina maybe she really is a christian
with pierce nipples which is now
something that none of us will ever
forget
and we still have a tie what
so we're going into a second tiebreaker
we're gonna give you both
20 more seconds another 20 seconds okay
gloves are coming off now i think
there's a lot of
bad juju behind christianity i mean
they're
homophobic they're sexist why would i
want to associate myself with a
community like that
i had a friend go she was completely
open-minded and then read the bible and
now she's like
super judgmental and christian and
carries a bible with her everywhere and
it's just it's awful i mean i've seen
what she's become
the reason that i left religion as a 13
year old was because i was coming to
turn to my sexuality
i'm gay um it didn't vibe with me i was
i felt really persecuted
at a young age so atheism was the first
place where i felt accepted and
myself and valuable and
that was really big for my my growth and
my development
i'm gonna vote for katie nina's anecdote
was more specific
felt more real i think what katie said
was just definitely superficial
i'm gonna vote for katie again nina
seems nervous katie just seems kind of
pissed
yeah whatever i'll just vote for you
again and the person eliminated this
round
is katy
i swear that joey is like directing
people to vote for me
he is the mole i feel it in my heart
uh i have a question for joe you use a
lot of uh religious
language how does your atheist lens fit
into that anthropology has been a very
enlightening way for me
enlightening uh it's been a very really
way
it's been a very revealing way for me to
like like see atheism in its beauty but
i actually didn't want to ask um about
like you know like
about rituals that we follow that are
not associated to religion so nina you i
talked about like you know having your
tarot card
i also do a little bit of tarot i like
you know following the horoscope as well
and like you know seeing you know like
the stars
i love emma's reaction here joey and i
are like if they believe in tarot cards
what else might they believe in
i feel like astrology is irrational is
believing in god i don't know
i just don't understand the basis of it
because that's so that's that's
a scientific you should find meaning
wherever you want to find meaning and i
think
you know like i'm a taurus son a cancer
moon and rising
uh with venus uh with venus in pisces
you know you know it's like
even if i did believe in astrology i
wouldn't say this in an atheism game
this is a bold strategy nina just seems
like she's nervous i'm just gonna call
that out well she was like
almost five eliminated the last round so
i feel like that's pretty valuable
i'm also a leo son so i'm very
extroverted for me like astrology and
like tarot
card reading whatever it's just like
it's fun it's really fun for me to like
you know think about the stars and think
about you know our connection with you
know
the world around us rio you've been kind
of quiet so what's one thing about
religion that you have like a moral
issue with there's not a specific asset
christianity i take issue with i was
severely depressed in middle school
and i actually used to pray
significantly not just like the hindu
gods to god
in general as a concept and i didn't get
better from that and then i went to high
school i started actually seeking real
help i saw therapy
and i realized that i could provide
comfort for myself in a way
apart from religion with the astrology
stuff
i'm a classic atheist man that that rubs
me wrong
my vote today is gonna go for evan he
hasn't really added anything valuable to
the conversation in my opinion
eeny meeny miny joe i'm gonna vote for
joe this time
i think i'm going to go with evan i'm
gonna have to vote for evan this round
i'm a leo son
cancer moon sad rising sorry buddy
and the person eliminated this round is
evan i really thought it was gonna be me
i'll take it as a compliment you know
maybe um
maybe i seem um no it's not a compliment
i'm not what i'm saying this is totally
ridiculous
give me a thumbs up if you want to
continue the game if not give me a
thumbs down if you think you already
caught them all and want to end the game
now
i don't really know what to do right now
oh my god i'm panicking
i don't know
they voted we're ending the game i
completely regret my decision
if the color turns green you guys win if
it's
red you all lost and the mole is still
in the game
in three two one
i got stuck with with two astrology
believers you guys this is like
my t-shirt is an astrology t-shirt
that's an astrology
it's an astrology shirt i don't even
believe in it it's just a cool design
the game is over and the atheists have
won that means that the winners will be
receiving a cash prize and we're also
going to be gifting them the akintu
experience
where you'll get to pick your favorite
basics from our new interactive apparel
brand
who is it will the mole please
raise your hand in three
two one
[Music]
so everything i said was true i grew up
in a catholic household became an
atheist
and then the boyfriend that i tried to
deconvert converted me
that's what made me trust you because i
was like wait i did i've done that
that's going to be suspicious i was like
christian boyfriend wait
i why who voted for evan and why that's
what i want to know that's the biggest
mystery of this
evan came for me i have to get you out
nina you and i
are on the same page you came for us
you're going down really attacked at the
end of the
of the last round they're stars aligned
i bet that happens
i didn't really know that people
identified in so many different ways
when they identified as atheists a lot
of people think that atheists
are immoral but you know in my
experience it's
usually the opposite their atheism is
often fueled
by seeing so much injustice in religion
i call myself a secular humanist because
atheism
is what you don't believe secular
humanism was what you do believe
i believe that most people want what's
best for
the world atheism is about happiness you
find happiness
and meaning within your persona within
your soul that does not have to attach
to religion i think that's good
[Music]